I'm here
shooting these last couple
of weeks here at Largo.
Largo.
And we wanted to take over a space,
and there goes Andy Richter sneaking by.
Hey!
(laughing)
Going back to the dressing
rooms there at Largo.
Yeah, going back to the
dressing rooms, that's right.
Thanks, Andy.
Who is that?
That's Andy Samberg!
He has no idea how...
I saw Palm Springs last night
and it was really awesome.
[Andy Samberg] Thanks, man.
I really liked it.
Whoa, that's pretty close.
He has no idea who's on the show.
He comes in, he doesn't know
I'm shooting an interview.
I've got to pee.
Jesus.
He's going to go to that little bathroom
at the end of the hall.
Little bathroom at the end of the hall.
You know
(crosstalk)
what kind of operation we're running here.
(laughing)
I feel like any minute now,
chickens are just going
to come running across.
Did you guys discuss maybe doing it on the
stage looking out or you
like the backstage better
cause of all the lights (crosstalk)?
No, no. The stage is right,
the audience is right here.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think I ever got up there.
I always wanted to,
I didn't stand up, you know,
back in the day, but...
Yeah, well maybe you will.
Maybe you'll come back here
once this place reopens or
you could just appear here
in a motion capture
suit from your own home
as you're (beep) into a diaper.
That'd be cool.
(beep) into a diaper, yeah.
(laughing)
You bleep the curses or do
you let the curses roll?
Man, it's a pandemic.
We let it all hang out.
That's cool.
How many curses would I have to say
to start getting bleeped?
I don't know.
I actually have no idea.
I have no idea, but who
could stop us anymore?
It's (beep) true in the (beep)
(beep) ass (beep) diaper.
Taking a big old dumpy (beep)
in the (beep) mocap (beep).
This is punk rock baby!
Go, go, go!
Oh man!
This is punk rock!
This is the CBGBs of comedy.
Look at that, look at my hair.
Mopping out!
Mopping!
(laughing) Oh yeah.
(groaning)
(beep) yeah.
(beep)
Andy's been in that
bathroom for a long time.
Yeah, Richter to be clear.
Oh, he says he's out.
Okay, here he comes.
Okay.
Well anyway, we get the
word out on Palm Springs.
Okay?
Thank you. Thank you.
Palm Springs is available
to stream on Hulu
and I promise you it is
one of the better movies
you're going to see for quite a while.
So see that film and really
terrific performances
and heartwarming.
And I'm very happy for you.
Cause you're also, you're
just terrific in this movie.
And I just know that this is a big deal.
This is a great movie.
So I'm proud of you.
Thanks buddy.
[Conan] Congratulations. Seriously.
Very happy.
Thank you. Thanks buddy.
I look forward to seeing you in person
so we can do this with
our hands and fingers.
We should see each other in person.
(laughing)
I'm not good with hand signals.
That was not subtle at all.
We should see each other in person, man.
(laughing)
Is that the right one?
I've never understood hand signals, Conan.
(laughing)
Andy Samberg, thank you very much.
Thank you buddy.